so it seems I'm sure you've noticed that
there's always some kind of campaign
going on with the aim of dismantling the
dreaded masculinity and the latest
campaign comes to us courtesy of a
menswear company called bonobos bonobos
wannabes I really I'm not really trying
to pronounce it but um this this week
they launched their hashtag evolve the
definition that's what the campaign is
called evolve the definition which they
hope that through the sale of pink
Blazers and through Twitter activism
will change society's conception of
masculinity because of course pink
Blazers are very unmanly as opposed to
this I don't know what I have on this
baby blue weird shirt I have which is
which is of course very manly but um
according to is a spate I don't even
know what color CI anytime I wear an
unmanly color I have an excuse because
I'm colorblind so I really don't know I
never know what color I'm wearing I just
I just I just put something on and then
I judge based on the reactions of other
people and if people start making fun of
me then I know that okay I wore an
unmanly coat anyway the according to the
to the company the the traditional
definition of Miss masculinity is broken
and outdated and tired they say and it
needs to be updated to fit our you know
enlightened our enlightened
understanding of things now if you
haven't I wrote a piece about yesterday
I linked to it but if you if you haven't
had a chance when this is over go watch
the video that the company used to
launch this campaign because it's really
an amazing video it's amazing only
because it's exactly what you would
expect you know it's it's it's like
imagine a campaign by a trendy menswear
company to to change the definition of
masculinity energy just without even
seeing the video it success it's exactly
that what you have in your mind that's
exactly it
it features this kind of collection of
stylish feminine dudes with nice hairdos
reading synonyms format so it starts
with they have their phones out and then
they pull up the definition of
masculinity from the from the dictionary
and then they start reading synonyms for
masculinity or for masculine and the
synonyms are like macho manly strong
brawny powerful and then all the men
they react to that they react with
horror at that definition one of the guy
goes I'm not kidding one of the guy goes
my goodness why here I think it reads
though you know one of the synonyms for
masculine is uh is brawny and strong and
he goes my goodness and then another guy
wearing a beanie says I I think that
definition is a little is a little scary
he says his he's scared he's scared by
the definition of masculinity and then
the men all proceeded to give their own
definitions of masculinity and those
definitions include things like being
able to smile and cry and being brave
enough to be Who I am now I don't want
to get off on a tangent but
of course my whole video every video I
do is just consist of me getting off in
tangents so I don't know why even say
that but I just want to begin by noting
that because it's kind of a pet peeve of
mine it's not brave to be who you are
okay you shouldn't be proud of being who
you are you you don't really you don't
have any other choice but to be who you
are it's just that's who you are so you
have to be it see you'll get any credit
for being who you are you have no choice
in the matter so that's not who else are
you going to be is the question and by
the way if if yourself is a person who's
cowardly and weak then actually it's
brave to not be who you are
so it's never really brave to be who you
are because that's just who you are but
it is often brave to not be who you are
come something better
it's just I love what people do that
they they go you know I'm just being
myself and they think that that
justifies their behavior it's especially
it's something people say especially
when they want to justify some negative
characteristic about themselves and they
say well I'm just being myself and then
the answer to that is okay we'll have
you considered not being yourself
have you considered being something
better than yourself because yourself is
precisely the problem here that's what
that's what needs to change is yourself
yeah you're being yourself exactly
that's the issue be something better
because yourself isn't great right now
but that's kind of beside the point the
real point about this masculinity thing
is why I have three points that I want
to make
actually I think five three to five
we'll see first of all if if your
objective is to take hold of something
and change it
well fine but that's not evolving you're
not evolving anything in that case
that's not how evolution works as I
understand it its evolution is not
something that can be imposed from the
outside
evolution is a natural gradual internal
improving process and so if something
evolves that means that it should now
function better than it did previously
that that's what every it happens on its
own naturally and then by the end of it
this thing that evolves now should
function better than it did before so
okay let's look at this new version of
masculinity this effeminate version
emasculated this this you know a man a
man who cries and sobs and cares a lot
about fashion trends like that's the
okay so that's the new masculinity how
is that an improvement in what way does
a man now function better with this new
masculinity than he did before because
if we say that bears have evolved well
that should mean that the bear of today
is an improvement upon the bear of
10,000 years ago that's what it should
mean the bear of today is a better bear
he's better at being a bear so how is
the new masculine man better than the
older one
let's let's think about it the old
masculinity while it was maybe a bit
scary according to one of the guys in
the video it was a very scary thing but
at the same time if you could get past
the scariness of it the old masculinity
drove men motivated men to provide for
their families to protect their loved
ones to win wars to build to build
things to build civilizations among many
other accomplishments the new
masculinity now it may make men more
comfortable in many respects but what
are they achieving what are they doing
that traditionally masculine men could
not do as effectively
a traditionally masculine man will have
actual skills actual abilities that the
new masculine man does not have so how
what is the reverse of that it just it
seems to me that the the so called
evolved masculinity is more likely to
prevent men from functioning that it is
to help them function so then it's not
evolution second point we have this idea
that we have to change the definition of
masculinity because so many men today
fall short of that definition and so
therefore it needs to change but is that
the right response I would say no it is
and I would say that actually that's the
whole reason why we shouldn't change it
that men are falling short of it is all
the more reason to reassert the
definition to strengthen it fortify it
to declare it from on high it's not why
you should change it the fact that
people falling short of the definition
proves the necessity of the definition
you know the whole point of having a
concept like masculinity is to establish
standards it is to kind of draw lines
and to kind of clarify things
and masculinity for men just like
femininity for women has helped to
answer some very important questions
like what are men supposed to do what
are women supposed to do
how are men supposed to act how are
women supposed to act men and women in
society have always asked these
questions about themselves people will
always look at themselves and wonder
what am I supposed to do what is my role
what is my what is my place in society
but by getting rid of masculinity and
femininity all we've done is we've
removed the the answer to the question
but we have not removed the question
people are still asking the question but
all you've done is you've taken away the
answer which means that now there's
going to be confusion there's going to
be paralysis where there used to be
clarity and action the left seems to
think because the real problem that the
left has is not even with the answers to
the question it's what the question
itself they don't like the idea that a
man should do or shouldn't do anything
or that a woman should or should do they
don't like this idea that men and women
are looking at themselves and each other
and asking like what am I supposed to do
given that I am a man and what are you
supposed to do given that you're a woman
that's the question that the left
doesn't like so they want people to stop
asking it but they can't get people to
stop asking it so instead they just get
rid of the answers gender roles is
another example related to this you know
people in a marriage man and woman are
going to naturally wonder what they're
supposed to do what their role is how
they're supposed to work together to
accomplish the task of building and
sustaining a family and gender roles
answered that question but by getting
rid of the gender roles and replacing it
with nothing which is what we've done
now people are still asking the question
they're still wondering you know people
in a marriage are still like what am I
supposed to do how is this supposed to
work okay but now there's no answer
because we don't have the gender roles
so now they just end up confused and
marriages are dysfunctional because
nobody has any idea of how they should
function
rather than changing masculinity or
abolishing it to compensate for the fact
that men so often fall short of the
label I think what we should do is we
should challenge men to live up to the
label because it's true that not every
man is strong not every man protects but
every man should be strong and I don't
just mean physically obviously an 85
year old man is not gonna be physically
struck but every man should be
emotionally and morally strong
and I also believe that where physically
possible he should strive to have
physical strength as well because that's
you know something that men are needed
for in society every minute not not
every man protects his family but every
man should protect his family again not
just physically but spiritually these
are yes not every man does it not every
man wants to do it but every man should
do it and they should all want to do it
they should that's the standard
they should aspire to when you take the
standard away now we have nothing to
aspire to we have nothing to strive
towards
third thing
or am i I don't know what what am i
right my second or any of is Ahmet just
just a couple other quick notes you know
we say that we are changing the
definitions of things
so that people can be different like we
we look at a feminine man and we see
that he's different than other men and
so we say well we need to change the
definition of masculinity in order to
accommodate this guy and his differences
but do you know what actually happens
when you change the definition all
you've done is you've taken away that
guy's ability to be different
so even in the even in the dark old ages
when you had traditional masculinity and
that was like the standard there was
still some men who fell outside of it
was even okay to follow it maybe some
men or just just naturally kind of fall
more outside of that
and so you still had this diversity and
this this these differences in
personality but when you change the
standard by which the difference is
judged and by which the difference is
recognized as a difference then you've
gotten rid of the difference and so
you've actually by kind of expanding all
definitions and opening everything up in
this in this effort to to welcome
diversity you've actually abolished
diversity now nobody can be different
because there's nothing to be different
in comparison to the last point I want
to make here I think it's important
point
and I had to do this video at my car and
I don't know if you can tell I'm like
I'm burning up right now because it's
hot out and I have to keep the windows
up and I can't have the air on because
that would make noise that beats track
so I'm like sweating right it's like 95
degrees in the car I'm doing this anyway
wasn't gonna say these these this this
effort to to abolish masculinity is
being imposed upon society by our
cultural institutions it is not
something that most people want
that's why it's not a natural product
because when you when you in fact even
you look at a campaign like this it
change the definition of masculinity
most people react negatively to it they
think it's stupid and ridiculous you're
not pressuring her to pretend that she's
more progressive than she really is
she's going to admit that yeah you know
what I want a man who's a man you talk
to the average man as long as he doesn't
feel pressured to pretend that he's more
progressive than he really is he's going
to admit yeah you know what I want to be
a man I want a woman who's a woman I
want a woman who's feminine and who is
you know who is who is has a kind of
maternal instinct and who is that
womanly affection and compassion like
that that's what I wanted a woman I
don't want a woman who's who acts like a
man it's not what I'm looking for
that's what men and women still
naturally want even now even our
progressive age but it is our cultural
elites in our institutions academic
institutions the media Hollywood
government saw they're the ones who are
trying to impose this change on us and
so we should resist it
because we you know these this this
natural inclination that we have is
right and it's good
and we should stick to alright where to
cut it off there thanks for watching
everybody thanks for listening Godspeed